on dit jamais m
on pourrait dire james mais comme bien
des noms du jazz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai peint de photographes sert quand on
travaille ça consiste à faire des
photographies ensuite à retravailler
par-dessus pas exactement par dessus un
parfum de pardessus souvent avant
beaucoup avant quand tu fais un décor tu
photographies des gens devant le décor
dans le décor dans le décor et après tu
retravaille la photo marie de
retravailler par dessus c'est à dire
c'est une série d'étapes différentes qui
passe de la peinture à la prise de vue à
la photographie au tirage de laboratoire
des étapes finales des choses finalement
très classique mes études et coutu
d'efforts non qu'ils se disent plutôt
par transfert soit pas vraiment du
collage c'est plutôt des choses qui se
disent pas transparente c'est une
peinture
cette peinture ensuite est décentré et
sert de décor
ensuite ces gens qui cette quantité de
gens que je photographie dans la rue me
sert ensuite pour redessiner ou au
travail au laboratoire et finalement
toutes ces étapes s'arrête ça s'arrête
un moment ça s'arrête tout n'est pas
vraiment non plus puisque après les gens
voient les gens que tu fais des fois des
sérigraphies à partir de sa main oui ça
arrive voilà par exemple j'ai été
influencé par clic sont multiples
influences
ouais j'aime beaucoup quand au méliès
pour le cinéma max ernst qui a bouffé
décollage du bricolage etc
oui moi je suis pas très pour le mot
collage ce qui concerne mon travail
c'est pas vraiment les collages mai
pas particulière avoir un max
quand tu travailles chez toi tu écoutes
quoi qu'en musique
ouais on se serait bien passé
c'est franck des années soixante dix à
la musique pop bob rae je sais pas ça va
des doors satire extrêmes
musique classique aussi s'est pas
apaisée pas un goût particulier j'ai pas
le musicien ça vous convient aujourd'hui
une peinture photographie de louis jam
servi entre 5000 francs demandés tout
petit dans les petites photographie à
tard en trompant pour l'exemple là où il
en est bien sorti sais que c'est dur de
vendre des photos parce que non mais
c'est pas des originaux qu'on vend ce
sera mon temps des tirages fermeture
travail par dessus ça leur donne une
vraiment un art travaille pas
nécessairement deuxième est en tout cas
si je retravaille dessus c'est pas pour
leur donner une valeur par la lumière et
pour rejoindre le même principe que la
peinture je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'artistes qui ont déjà travaillé sur le
phénomène de reproduction vont citer les
puces et les warhol les choses comme ça
l est les plus proches je crois
qu'effectivement le marché encore des
problèmes avec ça je crois que d
habitude
maintenant va l'acheter de la peinture
et donc on a plus de chances d'être
connu plus vite si on est peintre que si
on fait de l'art avec autre chose mais
mais
à terme je pense qu'ils se passent
beaucoup d'autres choses que la peine
cuir en ce moment et qui a beaucoup de
moyens comme ça qui arrive un peu à
maturité est là pour tous la vidéo il y
en a d'autres
alors au début tu peignait des souvent
des peintres en pâture photographier et
elle est souvent des pannes tu as fait
jean michel basquiat tafer garrouste a
fait dire aux a fait fait boire ont donc
tu as fait tes copains commencé comme ça
fait quelque chose de très beau sur wii
ça a commencé avec des proches comme ça
les gens mais alors là par contre des
parties à faire des lézards à barbès d
raconte pourquoi tu es passé de ils ont
des pipolo aux anonymes
je crois qu'ils ont quelque chose en
commun c'est que c'est c'est l'extérieur
pour moi c'est à dire quand je fais la
peinture quand je suis dans mon
laboratoire aller voter les photos je
montre dans la situation d'un artiste
d'un peintre quoi ce que je suis tout
seul ces solitaires comme pratique la
photographie me permet de m'ouvrir
totalement sûr sur extérieur de me
nourrir de tout cet aîné réponds moi
s'il s'est élargie ont quand même de
placer comme ça des gens connus des gens
de tous milieux
ouais vidal et commence à mettre ton des
corps dans la rue c'est par un village
où ça change a l'air de penser à ça
reste quand même et même le même prédit
même à ma porte
moi j'apporte à peu près les mêmes
choses évidemment ce qui est très
différent c'est l'histoire de conscience
et tout ça c'est que les gens dans la
peinture sont des gentils par métier
contrôler leur image
moi j'en terminer comme ça que vous nous
sort de provocateur par jour à leurs
propres à limoges les gens dans la rue
c'est différent c'est peut-être plus
sérieux parce que c'est des gens qui
sont totalement inconscients de ce qu'on
peut en faire ensuite quoi donc c'est
une image comme ça que je que je
prendrais pas de reprise kim à prendre
oui ce sont sûrement c'est de se mettre
en place et de plus personnel en tout
cas c'est une suite ok tu as nécessaire
on peut voir en ce moment dans ton
travail au musée d'art moderne de la
ville de paris oui c'était la masse
critique alors sa masse critique oui
c'est jusqu'à quand je peux mois de mars
non je crois que tu sais pas et s'il
fallait lui je sais pas si tu devais
rester toi une définition dans le
dictionnaire des fans ce serait quoi
oui j'avais déjà six en pratiquant la
photographie je pourrais être dans le
dictionnaire des peines serait pas mal
c'est pas loin de l'être
il est premier mais ya quand même pas
mal de gens qui ont fait les choses très
sérieuses de kim
son peu reconnue et de la photographie
c'est ce à quoi la peinture pour toi moi
je me bats pour moi ça me serre
personnellement en tant qu'artiste façon
très personnelle mais je pense que ça ne
doit servir à rien face à serra peine
chose à faire de l'argent ça sert à
faire vivre les gens c'est tout un
milieu mais en soit je crois que ça tout
ça c'est un peu
ces effets secondaires de ces germes de
la vie ce qui sert à rien ouais c'est
sûr c'est en fait en tout cas
la peinture je crois que c'est 105 ça ça
va et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu